if we were to look at baseball in a
20-year period and we said okay during
that 20-year period no problem take
moguire out take Sosa out take bonds out
take Clemens out take these guys out
what the hell is baseball
take those products out who the hell is
coming to watch the game who's trying to
see the the temperament the mindset the
travel the sacrifice the nine months out
of there you're on the road you're
having kids you're going through all
this stuff take all that stuff out
nobody's coming to watch the
commissioner play they're coming to
watch you play right Michael made a
comment about this in the last dance
when they were talking about you know
they don't come to watch the GM play
they don't come to watch the owner play
they come to watch us play
[Music]
[Applause]